howdy folks Maxwell here and today we're
checking out a little game called
minimum but dare I say there's not much
minimum about it because it's got combat
it's got crafting it's got things that
kind of look like Titans and to help
explain all of that I'm joined by Norman
nazarov with human head Norman thank you
for sitting down or letting me sit down
in your space I'll check out the game
with you thank you for coming man I'm
really glad to have you here let's go
ahead let's dive right in what is so
minimum is a third-person 5vs5
team-based shooter wonderful so focuses
on multiplayer we've got a really cool
mode called Titan mode okay which we're
trying to combine elements of old-school
like Unreal Tournament and quake 3
shooter with some of the more modern
elements from MOBA games so we've got
there's pre farming there's Titans
there's an objective based gameplay
we're gonna be shooting down towers at
any point actually you there are turrets
okay but not necessarily on towers
sometimes they're on walls sometimes
they're in different places let's go
ahead and jump right in here I can I can
see for myself over so first we'll just
walk you through the this is the other
main screen okay a lot of people like
you do so this is your armory where you
have your load outs which you know most
people be familiar with from other kinds
of shooters this is where you can decide
what weapons you want to bring into the
game with you we've got five different
core classes of weapons that art that
are available
there's the spread rifles or bullet hell
okay which is when named for the games
that people like so that within minimum
our weapons level up so with kill
streaks okay every time you kill someone
they drop a powerup you can collect it
and that levels up the current weapon
you got equipped so for the bullet hell
as you level it up it gets additional
streams of bullets he goes from like
once you're involved on the middle to
like five in the end one that I click
this here we can see these are what the
different levels of sweet Y so here in
Swedish your barrels exact so the barrel
is gonna have additional bullets that
come out of it okay and then those like
all reset with you start what you got so
I'm going to die oh yeah so for for
weapons was a totally kill streak base
so once you die you go back to level one
so having a level five weapon is
you bonus but then everybody's probably
gonna come in said they're gunning for
you it's usually as well we've also got
sniper rifles we have katanas which
actually you end up with two of them as
they level up and the light on fire as
they go up
we've got plasma lectures shotguns all
the kinds of guns that you expect sure
but with a with a wacky or twist on them
because they said we want to be more
like that Unreal Tournament click three
sort of vibe to it so there's a bunch of
weapons here you can see that say like
not yet crafter or Anita schematic so
the way that you get weapons in minimum
is through our workshop here so in the
workshop you have schematics and these
are the plans that you use to make your
weapons it's like in the case here we've
got a grenade launcher which is a
variant of the of the plasma launcher
and so you can see this is sort of the
exploded exploded a little parts go
together and you see what it looks like
once at all okay once it's all assembled
I'm sooner to make things from a
schematic you need crafting materials so
these are the costs and they're listed
down here and then you can also see a
period shows you how many materials
you've got available so to make a weapon
you have to first get a schematic and
then you get all crafting materials that
you need and then each weapon has a
different kind of combination of
components that it wants to make those
so and then once I craft a weapon do I
didn't have access to like all five
levels yeah yeah yeah so once you graft
a weapon you've got it for good you can
put in your loadout you can use it as
many times as you want we've got access
to all those five power levels in the
game what's cool about the about the
schematics are two things so we're going
early access right which we haven't
mentioned yet we're gonna be launching
early access we're gonna put out a ton
of content updates as we go so we're
starting with just the weapon crafting
we're also gonna have upgrades and mods
you can enter your weapons so once you
have a schematic you can craft more than
one grenade launcher and then put
different mods and different upgrades in
it to me to make one grade launcher
that's just all about damage may be a
different grenade launcher that's got
longer flight times on the projectiles
and a shorter fuse okay you can sort of
mix it up and decide how you want yours
depending on how it fits your playstyle
exactly and we also are gonna be
supporting Steamworks
so trading inventory the marketplace all
that kind of stuff so like I don't have
the fork launcher it's gonna
here they do the Titan katana schematic
so maybe I'll craft a Titan katana and
then trade for someone who's got a work
launcher schematic or a fork launch and
so you want to have that sort of
interaction between players fantastic
well let's let's dive in I want to see I
want to see in the C game all right
I'm gonna show you one more thing before
we dive in just this is the last the
last important gameplay aspect so we
have blueprints is they're a little bit
different than cymatics we're starting
with armor these are things you actually
craft during a map so they use a
different set of materials that you
acquire by coming enemies and achieving
objectives and stuff as you can craft
there's helmets body torso and legs
pieces and they give you different stat
benefits for the Berserker helmet gives
you additional damage but you also take
more damage okay the multi jump one
gives you multi job and you can upgrade
them so there's three levels to it so by
the end of the multi jump it's a quad
jump parent boots which gives you
additional abilities okay so this is
sort of like a twist on the general like
item vendor that's exactly the twist on
that and the thing you see in that in
most MOBA games you buy items exactly
let's get it in so we have automatic
matchmaking so you just hit play now and
then choose the more you want to play
and we're only launching with titan mode
okay but that's also our cool isn't I'm
pretty happy the best foot forward
that's it for it exactly so this is
where you see your loadouts so you've
got is where you would pick which weapon
so let's go get two weapons and one
light peaceful and what the fights a
wife yeah so for devices we have two of
them initially that's a pretty standard
for a grenade and then we have a
deployable grenade turret so this is
somewhere actually this match has
already started to be join the match in
progress not one so this is a free tier
and that particular creep that he's
trying to chase down as the golden creep
so like like in MOBA games one of the
things you want to do is farm up creeps
in between rounds so they're at the top
of the screen you see two numbers
there's the 8 and the 600 and that shows
how many creeps your team has farmed and
so the more that you firing the creep
phase the stronger your Titans will be
when they respawn and so the golden
creep which is why their Titan icon just
turned yellow the golden Creed gives a
bunch of additional because they've got
like the golden creep boost exactly so
in addition to just having more creeps
overall they've also got the golden few
so they're pretty far ahead three now
this is math way out
all through the traditional mobile
styles like set lanes with a jungle type
environment in the middle I mean so that
this is these are the Creek areas so
there's two on this map and they're in
this sort of cave area so they're off to
the sides and there's one lane going
down the middle where the titans march
so there's one main with creep farming
areas on either side so you can kind of
think of the creep farming area is kind
of like the jungle in the sense that
there you know it's twisting a little
more closed in the sight lines are
shorter and so the but it's also sort of
separate from the main lane exams like a
lot of the combats been exactly yep so
people tend to break up into the creep
farming areas during the creep phase and
then you have to balance between doing
it what you do it and then you share
have to break up from from a team's
rating perspective of whether or not you
were farming the creeps on your side of
the map okay where are you invading the
enemy side of the night right Brian stop
them performing theirs but now the
titans have respawned they march down
this is the lane that he's walking down
here mm-hmm
and so now they're gonna fight up in the
middle of it uh looks like art Titan
doesn't deck and yeah I saw it in the
articulate because it has so much more
creep farm to it it took about half
their Titans health off in a single hit
normally even take about a quarter of
its health um so our Titan is about to
wreck oh and it looks like we can assist
in these time cards well I think our
time together but yeah the players can
do damage the Titans player weapons are
a lot less effective your Titans are I'm
at least at level 1 if you get your
weapons up to level 5 with the spread
rifle if you can get real close to Titan
and get all 5 bullets on it if it does a
lot of damage but now these are the
defensive walls that came up we just
walked past we gotta get maybe not
that's teamwork right there okay some
soon it was the base but defensive also
late are you building defenses on the
map whistle blew ideas these icons this
is where the walls come up out of the
ground
oh they raised up when the Titans
approached and so you see this one's
been destroyed here and if he keeps
walking forward he'll see that that died
but there was a wall over the Titan was
beating on okay I'm so Titans are the
only things that can do damage to walls
so that's why you need a power precise
score to keep it safe because that's
ultimately how you win the game is it
scoring your Titan all the way down to
any base the Titan I'm in here is gonna
refuse in a racket exactly
does any player control the Tyner is the
tank completely inside man yeah yeah yep
he just spawns marches down the middle
fights the other Titan and then it
starts beating on walls if he wins I
don't know looks like we just crafted up
a little bit of oh yeah this is that's
the image blueprints cracking and I was
talking about so I think it's like armor
gives them additional health and and and
defense okay so you live longer better
the cost of moving a little bit slower
so he's also got things like these are
the speed boots who's gonna make them
just run faster okay so you can like MIT
mix and match exactly yeah and each one
of these will have further upgrades the
materials that used to make him you see
down the lower left there's there's two
icons now Jones and yes for certain
shards and fragment okay or we call them
gems and awkward circle so the awkward
circles are sort of the base crafting
material and everything cost some amount
of awkward circles okay and then the
gems are the more they're like higher
tier so it's kind of like vestment gas
in StarCraft the higher tech units are
upgrades for things you need more they
need us the basic items just need the
awkward circles and so that's the okay
so then I imagine like you get one
resource from building bad guys and
another resource just found yeah so
pretty much everything you do give some
amount of the awkward circles the CREZ
so the crystals come from killing
enemies or killing players in these two
the purple one I just got collected or
okay you also get him from killing
creeps and from killing Titans okay
everything else just drops the dog
reserves now then like when that
currency drops on the map can anybody
like run over yeah no oh yeah my puppy
okay and in some ways until they enemies
can snipe Mia but it's also somewhat of
a strategic decision so if you've
already crafted all the fruit you want
if they're all good to go even exactly
but let your buddy take pick it up and
same thing with the power-ups at level
up your weapons that's the blue the blue
that blue thing that you picked up you
can let one of your other allies grab it
if you've already got a level 5 weapon
like there's no sense in grabbing more
your buddy rabbit turret there's like
throughout his quite the turret turtles
Oh a little bit of behind-the-scenes
behind our names Council Oh PC here a
man's B so then is there say it looks
like the so he deployed the turn and it
looks like now it's running on a cool
man yeah so it's gonna recharge the cool
down until he can use it again that's
why I guess like Zola knew what he was
doing so he needs the command grenade
yeah so it'll recover and cool down and
then you only put one turn at a time
okay so he couldn't put another one out
until that one was either destroyed or
in some way but he'll be able to put a
new one out as soon as that now is the
blue bar up there does that indicate
that like our Titan is back on the field
that's your Titans hell yes the titans
already respond and our Titan has
already destroyed their time so during
that farming phase oh I wasn't even
paying attention so the blue team just
dominated that running pace we are kind
of cleaning it up right now he creep
differentially here so this is gonna be
over this business is pretty much over
at this point using a bug through this
last wall and they're gonna make a
desperate attempt on the super home so
he's doing some work but I think it's
too late we can see that their second
wall is already down he served with the
people's hero momentarily
Oh God there we go there there it is and
of course the cool action pose that's
right cool action pose for the end
victorious and this is one of our two
maps this is or this one's called the
desert canyon and unfortunately the
desert canyon again that's alright I
said so anything else like post games it
looks like yeah this is yeah all night
yeah so missions are something that you
get periodically
they'll give you different goals to like
you know kill assert number creeps in a
match or like win five matches of the
particular weapon or that kind of thing
and so by completing missions you get
additional
crafting material rewards so it's a way
to get more more graduate rails to make
more guns okay so even if you lose the
round you can still completing up a
mission they feel quite so bad exactly
yeah and you get rewards just for
completing a match so you get a bonus
for winning but just being in the magic
you'll still get something yeah all
right Norman well is there anything else
you want to touch on real quick before
we wrap it up we're super excited to go
really access so they'll be really soon
very soon early access and we want to be
at ruler early access game link we're
looking for a serious feedback from
players we want then beginning free demo
time exactly yeah exactly this as yes
it's paid betas like no we actually want
a conversation with the players and want
them to let us know what they like about
it what they don't like about it what
kind of features people want to see
we're gonna make sure that we're you
know we're present on this team uniforms
we're gonna like regular screaming
online and so we want the players to
really talk to us and we'll show them
things early stuff that's not done yet
we've got a new map it's in progress is
about to be percent done we're gonna
throw that up on our dev blog pretty
soon and let the players I take a look
at it and tell us like if you guys think
and there's any idea any idea of like a
release date release window ah very soon
okay in the next few weeks here will be
one early access wonderful thanks for
sit down chat with me thanks a lot for
coming I appreciate it